This week on Ask a Teacher, we answer a question from Doyeon in Korea about the usage of three similar words.
本周的《名师答疑》中，我们回答来自韩国Doyeon关于三个相似单词用法的问题。
Here is the question:
问题是：
Hello.
你好。
I want to know the differences between
我想知道它们之间的区别
the beach, . . . coast and shore.
海滩、海岸和滨岸。
Thank you.
谢谢。
You ask a useful question, Doyeon. Beach, shore and coast are related words, but they have some important differences.
你的问题很有用，Doyeon。Beach、shore和coast是相关词汇，但有一些重要区别。
Beach
Beach（海滩）
The word "beach" is the most specific of the three words.
“Beach”是这三个词中最具体的。
The Collins online dictionary defines beach as "a nearly level stretch of pebbles and sand beside a sea, lake, etc., often washed by high water."
柯林斯在线词典将beach定义为“海、湖等旁边近乎平坦的卵石和沙地带，常被高潮淹没。”
Ocean beaches are popular places to visit.
海洋海滩是受欢迎的旅游景点。
We often use the phrase "at the beach" to express the idea of spending time in the general area of the beach, as in the following example:
我们常用“at the beach”表示在海滩周边区域度过时光，例如：
They will vacation at the beach this summer.
他们今年夏天将在海滩度假。
We usually say "on the beach" when describing specific activities we do there:
描述在海滩上的具体活动时，我们通常用“on the beach”：
She went for a walk on the beach.
她在海滩上散步。
I'm going to spend my afternoon on the beach.
我打算下午待在海滩上。
They are playing football on the beach.
他们正在海滩上踢足球。
Coast
Coast（海岸）
The Learning English Word Book defines coast as "land on the edge of the ocean."
《学英语词汇手册》将coast定义为“海洋边缘的陆地。”
We can use the word to describe a wide area, however.
不过，这个词也可以用来描述广阔的区域。
For example, Baltimore, Maryland is an East Coast city even though it is several kilometers from the Atlantic Ocean.
例如，马里兰州巴尔的摩是东海岸城市，尽管它距离大西洋约几公里。
Here are more examples of how we can use "coast" in a sentence.
以下是更多使用“coast”的例句：
The Florida coast has many nice towns and beaches.
佛罗里达海岸有许多美丽的小镇和海滩。
The coast of California extends over 1,300 kilometers.
加利福尼亚海岸线绵延超过1300公里。
Like the expression "at the beach," we can say "on the coast" when describing the general area, as in the following example:
与“at the beach”类似，我们可以用“on the coast”来描述一般区域，例如：
Her mother has lived on the coast for 30 years.
她母亲住在海边已有30年。
We can use the expression "off the coast of" to describe an area of ocean or sea relative to a place on land:
我们可以用“off the coast of”来描述相对于陆地的海域：
The island is about 60 kilometers off the coast of Africa.
该岛距离非洲海岸约60公里。
Shore
Shore（滨岸/岸）
The Merriam-Webster online dictionary defines the word "shore" as "the land bordering a usually large body of water."
韦氏在线词典将“shore”定义为“通常濒临大面积水域的陆地。”
Shore can sometimes mean the beach, but not always.
Shore有时可以指海滩，但并非总是如此。
For example, you might swim to shore and come out of the water onto a beach.
例如，你可以游到岸边，然后从水里走上沙滩。
But you could also come to shore at a port with no beach in sight.
但你也可能在一个看不到海滩的港口上岸。
And we can use "shore" when discussing the general area, just like we do with the word "coast."
和“coast”一样，我们也可以用“shore”来讨论一般区域。
The following example shows this meaning:
以下例子展示了这个含义：
The northern shore has many nice towns and beaches.
北部海岸有许多美丽的小镇和海滩。
For our readers and listeners, what are your questions about American English?
对于我们的读者和听众，你们对美国英语有什么问题吗？
We want to hear from you!
我们期待您的来信！
Do you like to spend time at the coast?
你喜欢在海边度过时光吗？
Send us an email at learningenglish@voanews.com.
请发送邮件至learningenglish@voanews.com。
And please let us know where you are from, too.
也请告诉我们你来自哪里。
And that's Ask a Teacher.
这就是《问老师》节目。
I'm Andrew Smith.
我是安德鲁·史密斯。